[Music]
your dad okay
damon wayans senior and he poem pops you
through know what I call I don't know I
just made that up for this Bob to the Z
father and six peas yeah I'm just he I
remember him talking about you all those
years that your dad was doing stand-up
he would talk about you in his act when
you were a baby and like when you were
growing up yeah and it wasn't always
flattering stuff that you'd necessarily
want broadcast oh absolutely you
wouldn't he made his living doing
stand-up talking about us talking about
his children just destroying us and now
as a grownup I don't really care but
like I was a teenager and he made this
like one bit it was basically like that
I would find any excuse to go up to the
bathroom and masturbate like like I
would come into the house and beg
spaghetti again I'll be right back
I gotta say spaghetti does it for me too
and then like you know like if I was
younger it wouldn't matter but I was
like that was like when I was trying to
like to score with the ladies like that
I would like go up to girls and be like
hey she be like wait a minute aren't you
that guy they like masturbates with
spaghetti and stuff now be like I'll be
right back I would masturbate I was
frustrated did you talk to your dad did
you say to your dad
please don't do that please don't bring
me up in your act I thought about doing
it but then I was like I mean I'm in
like like one of the best private
schools ever ever freaking fountain on
my front lawn like I'm just gonna enjoy
it
do what you got to do dad you do these
insults are paying for this half
salutely yeah you know I mean I was just
happy to have like a dad that you know
raised me and was you know taking care
of me like a lot of my friends growing
up they didn't have debts like they
didn't have actually none of them had
dads it was weird but because they
didn't have dads like I would like make
up stuff to like mess with them because
they didn't really know what dads were
like so just like do stuff they they
were always like complement about how
big my house was like dude your house is
so big I'm like yeah man yeah it's
because I have a dad all dads have
engines they come with mansions you
didn't know that that's the worst I've
ever heard
maybe like seriously like yeah man like
make up rules I'll be like alright so my
dad's gonna come in there's a couple of
rules you need to know before he comes
rule number one dads like to be referred
to as master they love stereotypical
Asian impressions and penis compliments
as many penises so these please have kid
kids have no idea idea your dad wouldn't
my dad will walk in there be like Oh
master way is that's a way house is big
and your penis is big big veiny penis
okay I'm gonna take a break I'm gonna
talk to your lawyer and your publicist
more with Damon Wayans Jr it is the
seconds to grab
you